so you started out as a kid actor in
Hollywood uh Different Strokes Webster
um Facts of Life uh did you want when
did you realize you wanted to be an
actor as a kid you know I fell into it
as a kid um because of my love of
superheroes I used to dress up almost
exclusively as Superman Batman you know
uh Spider-Man I was gonna say you were
saying the wrong Universe go on
I'm you know agnostic I love them both
just like James Gunn
um and you know I uh I was I was told
that I could not dress up anymore as a
superhero when I was a kid I had to come
dressed as a normal kid
um and uh so you know one day I I showed
up in normal clothes and then I raised
my hand to go to the bathroom like you
do you know in preschool and
kindergarten and she took me to the
bathroom and I you know pulled down my
pants and I was wearing swimming trunks
and she said uh you know why you're
wearing swimming trunks and I said
because today I'm Aquaman so I was you
know I probably should have said Neymar
if I wanted to stay within Marvel but
yes I was Aquaman and so I've always
been you know involved in
you know imagination and dressing up and
loving these characters and I kind of
got discovered
um dressed up as a superhero and um
found my way to doing a commercial when
I was four years old
and so I just kind of went from one you
know job to another it was a lark that
became a profession as a kid and they
ended up spending a lot of time on
sitcom sets in the 80s which was
incredibly helpful when I did one
division because it felt like a trip
down memory lane
um and also a bit of therapy too because
I got to kind of you know deal with this
crazy past of mine um but along the way
I just I fell in love with you know what
was happening behind the camera and the
directors and what they were up to and I
just wanted to ask lots and lots of
questions and then by the time I sort of
got out of college I knew that's kind of
that's what I wanted to do you did an
episode of Night Court as a kid
um is it possible that uh now that night
Court's been renewed for season two that
that kid will make an appearance on
Night Court Season Two as a grown-up and
you will direct the episode
oh my gosh that's a wonderful idea tell
them I'm available yeah have them give
me a call but I think they would they
would love it
I'm just um so I wasn't going to ask
this but um obviously I have stuff
behind me in my interview you have stuff
behind you in your interview I'm trying
to figure out the choices you made of
what to put behind you you know what I
mean oh yeah so what what's the stuff
behind you it's a mix you know it's a
mix um over one shoulder is Game of
Thrones which was
um a show that I absolutely loved
working on and was a really big sort of
turning point in my life and and the
kinds of cinematic large-scale things
that I
um could do and was being offered as a
result of David benioff and Dan Weiss
giving me a shot on that
um there's Rob mcelhaney as from the
night man cometh an episode of It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia show that I
worked on for most of my you know 20s
and 30s
um and uh some stuff from the the Geffen
Playhouse the theater that I ran for the
last six years
um some One Division stuff above my head
including a stark toaster from episode
one of lawn division some Sherlock
Holmes
um uh some drawings of Spider-Man and
Wolverine that I that I got when I met a
uh an anchor for Marvel when I was about
six or seven who was really kind to me a
guy named Bob wyacek and I met him on a
train and I told him how much I love
Spidey and he drew those for me and I've
kept them ever since they've been in my
office ever since
um yeah that's pretty much it it's funny
because all the stuff behind you is
stuff basically you worked on I'm just
like I'm a fan of these things you know
it's a little a little bit different um
you directed a lot of TV and I'm curious
and a lot of one episodes where you'd
step in direct an episode and then you
know you you go away which was that
besides Game of Thrones which obviously
is its own challenge
um which show was the toughest to step
in on you know for like one episode
um that required the most work and prep
to really get it I mean certainly the
first one you know taking that jump off
that Cliff when I worked on the show
Once and again uh edswick and Marshall
herskovitz great filmmakers found me
directing plays in a small field theater
and gave me a chance to Shadow on their
show and eventually Direct on their show
and um and that was terrifying you know
to kind of do that for the first time to
realize that you have 200 people looking
at you and you have to figure out how to
get everyone through the day and through
the through the episode that was that
was certainly stressful but you know
they all are I have to say before I
begin any job I'm up late at night
wondering if you know if I've got
everything worked out how it's going to
go
um you know I think the nerves are
actually a part of it you know I think
if I if I lose the nerves I'm probably
becoming a hack you know I I want to
stay invested so each job is is always
difficult uh jumping into why I get to
talk to you
um you directed the first episode you're
also an executive producer on the series
for people that don't realize when
you're the when you're directing the
first episode of a show like this can
you sort of take people through what
exactly that means in terms of or you
know how are you working with Tony in in
terms of the casting the aesthetic of
the show
um you know every aspect of it it's
essentially if I if I understand it
right it's your fingerprints on
everything yeah absolutely so Tony sent
me the script
um uh after he had adapted from the
novel so he'd already decided that this
was a you know a novel he wanted to
adapt and how he wanted to basically
approach it and I loved it it just kind
of left off the page to me I loved the
uniqueness of the voice the tone the
style and I certainly loved the central
character Pat off
um I'm a fan of I'm a fan of Thrillers
and Mysteries and I and I love comedy so
when you put them together it's really
exciting
um so he sent it to me there was no one
cast we had it hadn't been set up
anywhere it was with MGM as a studio
um so we um decided first to try to find
our ideal path off we made a list and at
the very very top of the list was
Christoph Waltz and the fact that he was
willing to meet with us let alone sign
on to it was just an incredible
um bit of lock-in I'm so grateful to be
able to to work with him he's a genius
and so once we had him on board then we
went around and tried to find the ideal
partner and
um and we end up luckily again with the
top of the list for us Prime video the
Amazon and they have been wonderful
Partners yeah can you sort of talk about
um uh uh the aesthetic of the show and
how you wanted to to film the first
episode because that's the blueprint
that everyone else is going to follow
right I you know it's rare when you read
something and you just you see it in
your head
um it happens to me every now and then
as a director but a lot of times you
struggle to kind of visualize things and
figure out the best way to tell the
story but this just kind of jumped into
my head and I felt like I was you know
chasing this you know this sort of
imaginary idea of the show the entire
time
um and part of it I think is just Tony's
writing is so excellent at the world
that he was that he was creating was
evocative and I felt like I had a sense
of what it should look like so
architecture was very important to me
like the sense of clean lines and and
you know in some ways it wanted to feel
you know a bit German in a sense you
know the way that you know Pat off is
um mysteriously from everywhere but the
way Kristoff is from that part of the
world
um and I looked a lot at Korean films I
I you know parasite obviously than
others it has that same tone that tone
that kind of rides the line between
comedy and drama and Thriller and we're
looking at something similar
um and I knew that I wanted to have this
juxtaposition between this very kind of
old world character and this New Gen Z
modern gaming company so and also the
idea that there's a kind of youngness to
that you know the games that they play
seem very innocent and simple uh which
stands sort of an ironic juxtaposition
to all the sort of more complicated
adult you know gay morality games that
are happening in the office as a result
of Pat top showing up so you know we had
to design the games from the ground up
we knew that they'd be a big lighting
aspects I wanted to just surround the
world with giant screens so that you
know during the day you had that
inundation of that kind of poppy
innocent gaming and then at night it
became this kind of lonely you know the
only way that office is lit really is by
these giant comp wear screens so you
know that was all you know so how we
started to build it Jess Hall who is a
cinematographer I've worked with a bunch
including on One Division was a great
partner on it and just kind of building
this kind of modern tech Noir was what
we were up to how much of the eight
scripts were done before filming began
on the first one
I I'm trying to recall I think episode
two I read an episode two and three
before we rolled cameras on episode one
I'm always curious how much of a show
gets to be block shot you know um but I
guess because of the office it's really
not uh almost happens there so I guess
it really doesn't matter because you
have your location block shooting can be
great it can be a hugely efficient way
to approach something we didn't do that
we actually shot the pilot for this like
a pilot you know we weren't 100 sure we
would continue on so we knew we had to
kind of build something that that could
be
um you know the start of something great
that people would be excited to keep
going with so so we made the pilot and
then we had to take a break afterwards
to make sure that everybody was digging
what we were doing and then they would
give us the the thumbs up to continue on
and do the rest of the episodes
um and they did block shoot the rest of
the episode so two and three four and
five which is just a great way to you it
allows you to be more flexible you can
go to really crazy locations because you
have more days to kind of fit everything
in how involved were you as an executive
producer how involved were you in the
editing room of the episodes two through
eight or is it sort of just like you
know what I mean yeah I not so much you
know I looked at the cuts and and you
have a few conversations along the way
um and I talked to you know several of
the directors as well you know just to
kind of talk about tone and style and
approach
um but really my my job was to edit
um the pilot you know to work really
closely to to make sure that that pilot
felt like a great template to start and
then after that you obviously want the
directors and Tony to kind of have their
um freedom and as they move forward for
soon to be fans of the series what do
you think they would be surprised to
learn about the actual making of the
show well it's interesting you know we
were talking about what the office place
is like post pandemic it wasn't really
in meant to be a pandemic related story
but just by virtue of the timing we were
making it you know it really has that
kind of the tension of re-entry about it
how are we going to be in relationship
to each other and we were filming it
during the Omicron uh Outbreak The Pilot
certainly and so we had to stop and I
think there's there is you know sort of
in the shots at least in the pilot that
that tension of oh my gosh you know this
the you know will we be shut down today
or not I mean there are literally shots
in the show where you know people are
wandering around just a little bit
suspicious of each other you know as we
were filming I think that probably
helped create that tension
um you know luckily we're fine and
everyone was healthy
um but it is you know it is a challenge
certainly in the the modern world I
definitely have other things to talk to
you about
um I was disappointed that you were not
going to be able to make Star Trek
um I I had heard through the grapevine
that the script was coming together uh
and I'm just curious have you actually
said what your movie was going to be
about no I haven't you know and I think
I'm probably not really allowed to speak
too much about it because I think what
they're still working on is a a version
of what I had been working on for the
time that I was involved so my thing I'm
a huge Star Trek fan but I actually and
I want to talk honestly about this I
actually think that making a Star Trek
movie for a hundred or 150 million
dollars I don't actually know if it's
going to work anymore and I say it
because there's a finite
um like the movies don't tend to perform
at these huge numbers at the box office
and I'm wondering it was the movie you
were considering without spoilers was it
one of those where it was going to cost
like 150 100 million dollars like a ton
of money part two of this is because I
actually think that the way forward on a
Star Trek movie is maybe to make one
that's like 30 to 50 million that's hard
sci-fi aimed right at the fans and if it
gets other people great
it's an interesting question you know I
think um in our day and age now anytime
you go to space in a movie it's
expensive and when you're flying around
in the Enterprise even if you're going
to land and be in one place for a long
time it's still pretty expensive uh you
have a large cast as well many of whom
are really you know well known as
because they're amazing and
um and so just bringing that group
together again isn't a cheap you know uh
event so I think yes the movie that I
was planning to make was going to be a a
large tent pole film you know and I
think that one of the things that JJ has
done so well is that you know he'll be
the first to admit he wasn't um he
didn't grow up being a giant Star Trek
fan even though he's a fan now but he he
was a huge Star Wars fan and so I think
in rebooting it with Chris Pine and Zoe
and and Zach he
um brought a little bit of Star Wars to
it which I think helped expand its
audience you know in terms of
um the scope and the scale of it and the
energy of it and so I think that you
know that certainly is is the goal is
that to find more more of an audience
for Star Trek but I am like you a huge
fan of that
um and it was a real shame that yeah I
couldn't make the timing work on it I am
very much looking forward to um an apple
series called uh well I don't actually
know the title but it's Godzilla
um so I'm just curious how many episodes
is that series
um that is 10 episodes and how many did
you direct two of them so you did the
first two yep
um I am so curious about this and I know
obviously you can only say so much but
for fans where does it take place on the
timeline in relation to the movies you
know I can't really say because that's
part of the joy of it is is actually uh
timeline is a big part of the
storytelling so just want to say that's
part of it but I can't really say more
than that sure I'll say this um Godzilla
every time he shows up on screen is
expensive
um I mean it is not cheap to put
Godzilla or any monster on screen so I
obviously Apple spends money on their
series but how much did you sort of have
to like
figure out you know how many seconds of
Godzilla can we put in per episode
what's the max we can do you know what I
mean that the VFX conversation has to be
a huge part of that series it is it's a
part of everything obviously no matter
what the scale of something you always
run out of money eventually even if it's
Harry Potter or Star Wars Star Trek
whatever you run out of money Godzilla
you're right out of money
um but it's um less about counting up
shots although eventually you have to do
that
um and more just about storytelling you
know how much was Godzilla uh going to
factor into the story and and he has a
very important
um role to play and and how he factors
into the series is is a big part of it
so that was the bigger driver and then
and he's not the only Titan that you're
going to meet along the way so there's
yeah there's a VFX conversation uh
constantly happening in that they're
making another Godzilla movie right now
how much did you guys sort of talk like
are you doing your own thing and then
the movies can do their own thing you
know there is some overlap though we
were not heavily involved in talking
about it with Adam Wingard or his team
um legendary is the studio for our show
as well as for the films and so they
sort of sit at the juncture there
between the two and they have a
mythology Department there which is
wonderful and so they weigh in on how
things might overlap how you know
certain creatures need to stay on one
side or the other and you know so there
is a lot of conversation about it but in
terms of the sort of how closely the
narratives over line uh overlap it's not
as um involved to say an MCU kind of
Disney plus to film crossover it's less
um organized than that you I believe are
directing another Marvel property coming
up I'm sure you're in prep mode right
now
um what was it what is it like actually
getting the keys to the Fantastic Four
um and being the person who's going to
bring that to screen in the MCU I have
loved these characters since I was a kid
um and so it is a huge joy to be able to
work with them spend time with them
every day a to bring them into the MCU
is also a huge Joy so it's it's that
it's just the excitement of being the
kid who who found them you know when I
was six seven eight and now being able
to work with them on the big screen is
it's amazing do you think you're going
to be are you just focused on Fantastic
Four this year do you think you could be
directing something else I don't think
so you know I'm still finishing up the
Godzilla project you were mentioning
um we're in post on that and have a few
more months on that
um but Fantastic Four is pretty much my
life until Valentine's Day of 2025. I
mean it's very tough to have to spend
that much time with those characters
right
um so listen a lot of people online have
been uh talking about rumors with
casting and all this BS
um are you casting right now or what can
you tease people in fact of like where
you're at in the pre-production of FF
um all the casting stuff that you see
here is just rumors we we are you know
early in our process us there
um we have nothing to announce right now
and certainly when we do we'll let you
know when do you actually because you
have a release date
um do you have the I look do you know
when you might start filming like have
you sort of mapped out the schedule yeah
early next year
the answers are getting shorter as I get
into FF mode
let me ask you guys what did you learn
because obviously you had such a
successful with long division it's like
I mean it's an incredible series what
can you sort of talk about what you
learned making one division working with
Marvel that you are now applying to
making FF and a big feature film Marvel
is a wonderful place to work I was
thrilled to be able to come back and
work with them because even though they
produce the biggest movies it's a very
small family of people that you're
collaborating with they're all lovely
people
um who are passionate about what they do
and so
um you are working with huge film fans
everyone is making the same movie you're
all moving in the same direction and and
that's just a joy and it's not very
often that that happens especially when
you're dealing with something on a
really large scale uh like the FF
um it's it's really fun to be back you
know when you join something for the
first time when like I did on One
Division you're just meeting everybody
for the first time now it's feels like
you're you're spending time with your
family
um which is wonderful and uh and so it's
it's a great it's a great office to show
up to every day I'm out of time but I'd
like to just ask one more thing if you
don't mind Marvel has all these upcoming
projects and I'm curious if you went did
you say to them I want FF did they say
to you are you interested in any of
these upcoming films like how did you
land on FF versus say an Avengers movie
okay FF was just the the film that made
the most sense in the conversation
um you know it's it's the it's the one
that I think I
um naturally gravitate towards um you
know there's there's the reason I love
Star Trek I'm sure is a big part of why
I love the Fantastic Four they are they
share a great sense of optimism and the
idea of looking to the stars and
Technology can solve everything and
coming together as a family either a
real family in the case of FF or the
family that you that you find in the
case of the Enterprise and so there's
just a lot of a lot of things about the
property that appealed to me and I'm
thrilled that I was able to to be the
one that that could do it listen man I
couldn't be more excited for you doing
the film
um and I'm so happy for everything
that's been going on in your career you
know Godzilla everything else and
consultant
um I'm just really happy for you thank
you I really appreciate it it's great to
spend time with you today thank you